الان الى العاصمه الصوماليه مقديشو حيث
قالت مصادره طبيه وامنيه ان خمسه اشخاص
على الاقلوا واصب عدد اخر بينهم مسؤولون
حكوميون في الهجوم الذي استهدف الفندق
الواقعه قرب القصر الرئاسي في العاصمه
الصوماليه والذي يرتدوها عاده المسؤولون
وموظفون حكوميون وسياسيون وقال قوه الامن
الصوماليه ان الاجهزه الامنيه نجحت في
انقاذ المسؤولين الحكوميين والمواطنين
داخل الفندق واضافتناها لا تزال وتنفذ
عمليه امنيه للقضاء على المسلحين الذين
تصفهم بالارهابيين
مزيد من المعلومات والمعطيات حول ذلك معنا
من مقديشو مراسل الجزيره عمر محمود اذا
عمر ضعنا في الصوره بشكل اقرب
المعلومات الاخيره فان هناك استمرار
المواجهات بين الشرطه الصوماليه وبين
المسلحين المتحسنين في ذلك الفندق
المستهدف ما زالت جاريه وما زال يصنع
تبادل النار متقطع بين الف ليله والاخرى
والقوات الشرطه الصوماليه واجهزه اخرى من
الاستخبارات ما زالت همم
عجزت مواقعها والدفاعاتها في محيط هذا
الفندق ولا الفندق هو فندق في الروز وهو
فندق قريب من القصر الرئاسي ويسكنه عاده
المسؤولون الحكوميون
والوزراء والنواب الى الان منذ الثانيه 10
ساعه ما زال هذا الفندق همم يشهد مواجهات
بين القوات الشرطه الصوماليه وبين
المصلحين المتحسنين من جانبها القوات
وماليه ما زالت تقول انها على مشارف وعلى
على المشاري في الانتهاء من هذه العمليه
وان هناك همم تحييد للمسلحين في زاويه
ضيقه من الفندق لكن حسب الشهود العيار
وحسب مشاهداتنا ما زالت تصنع همم ويسمع
بين الاثنين والاخرى تبادل النار بين
المسلحين وبين قوات الشرطه هناك طبعا
انتقاد همم من جانب الحكومه الصوماليه
وميجانب البحث ال- بعثه الاتحاد الافريقي
في في الصومال لهذا الهجوم الذي يعتبرون
انه يستهدف الاماكن والفنادق المدنيه التي
فتحت خصيصا الاتجاه ولا دخل لها همم
بالحكومه الصوماليه لكن همم من جانبها همم
همم حركه الشباب المجاهدين قالت حسب اورده
موقع محسوب عليها انها استهدفت هذا الفندق
لانه كان يقوي مسؤولين الحكوميين وهمم
النواب برلمان وق همم مسلحين تابعين لهم
ما زالوا يسيطرون على هذا الفندق القريب
همم حسب همم على احد تعبيرهم من مواقع
حصاصه للحكومه الصوماليه وان الحركه قادره
حسب هذا البيان على ضرب اي اي مكان واي
موقع همم في همم المسؤولون الحكوميون
العموم ما زالت المواجهات مستمره وما زالت
القوات الشرطه الصوماليه تقول همم على
انها بسدد انهاء هذه المهمه وايضا همم
هناك همم يتزامن هذا همم هذا الهجوم في
وقت تشهد مناطق واسعه في الصومال
المواجهات بين الحكومه الصوماليه وبين همم
حراسه شباب المجاهدين همم لالتزاع السيطره
من هذه المناطق شكرا لكم عمر محمود مراسل
الجزيره من قديم